good afternoon
my name is adam cohen along with michael
lin
i am one of the co-hosts this afternoon
welcome to the session on emerging high
throughput microscopy methods
for imaging brain activity recent
advances
have dramatically improved the
resolution in time
space and throughput of brain imaging
tools
today we will hear about these exciting
developments from some of the leaders
in the field
and my name is michael lynn i'd like to
reiterate the welcome thank you all for
joining us
so we have a very exciting program today
so i won't um
i won't keep you guys away from it too
much longer um but just uh two reminders
before we get started
um first is um if um you will see at the
bottom of your screen that you can
you can submit questions to the uh to
the speakers
um you can submit those at any time we
are going to go through them at the very
end of this session
that is about an hour from now but you
can submit them at any time
and if you could um if you could
indicate uh if there's a particular
speaker who your question is directed to
if you could just type their name
um at the beginning of your question so
we know who to direct the question to
i mean we'll be organizing and fielding
those questions at the very end
and so um um we have a very exciting
lineup with uh valentina
emiliani monsoe sarah abramson gerald
mertz casper kotorsky
nazi and alipashya vaziri um and we will
get started thank you very much
first of all i would like to thank adam
and michael for having organized this
virtual symposium
and i wish that everybody in the
audience stays healthy and safe during
these
challenging times so the interest of my
lab is to develop and use advanced
optical methods for the manipulation of
neuronal
circuits using waveform shaping and
optogenetics
as you probably know conventional
experiments using optogenetics today
are done using a visible light white
field illumination
and the cell type specificity is a
reached
because of the precision of genetic
targeting
so with this approach it was it has been
possible to
achieve a very precise mapping of brain
functioning with the
cell type specificity however
the use of white field illumination
can only synchronously activate or
select
entire population of cells while looking
at activity of
circuits under physiological condition
we know that
in most of the case this is
characterized by the fact that even
genetically identical cells can have a
very divergent activity pattern
so today if you want to start
manipulating uh those kind of circuits
and eventually even mimic
their activity with the ultimate goal of
being able to link
specific special temporal activity
patterns to
behavior we need somehow to replace the
wall
region optogenetics to what we called a
few years ago circuits optogenetics
meaning with this a combination of
techniques that enable
to manipulate single or multiple targets
independently in space and time
so in this talk i will show you uh
quickly
uh a quick overview of which has been
the most important
technical challenges that has to be
faced to
uh reach the condition to perform
circuits optogenetic
so first of all we need of course to uh
get a cell resolution and for that we
need to replace
uh single photon white field
illumination with focus to photon
excitation
so to be able to uh
reach a single target embedded in a
three-dimensional scattering volume
and to increase the the efficiency of
two photon optogenetics
in my lab we have proposed to combine
two
uh approaches to uh with to fold an
excitation
the first one is called computer
generated holography so here
the key element is a special lay
modulator
that enable to modify the propagation of
the light so that at the sample plane
you can get an illumination shape that
eventually
precisely reproduce the shape of the
original target
and to also get precision with respect
to the axial propagation
we propose to combine computer generator
holography with the
technique of temporal focusing where now
the key element is a dispersive grading
which enable to to uh excite the sample
with an
uh with a laser beam having a short
pulse selectively at the focal plane
and so therefore with the optical
sectioning independently for
on the uh lateral ladder spot shape
so we were able to to show that the use
of the combination of those two
approaches enable a very
efficient current integration when used
to excite
uh cells expressing an optic
an optogenetic channel and
for example when this is combined with
different types
in vivo we showed that parallel
illumination enabled to reduce the
illumination time
to generate a single action potential
down to
uh two five milliseconds and because we
can keep the illumination time so short
we could also reach some millisecond
temporal jittering means that we can
very precisely control
the spike in time we then also shown
that the use of parallel illumination is
compatible with the use of opsin with
the fast
photocycles and this has the advantage
that they can be used to trigger
action potential train a very high
spiking rate
up to 80 under theirs
so this is as far as concern the
temporal solution then the next
important step
was to control the special resolution
and for that they have been in the past
year many labs that has developed
different variants of what we call
summary street adoption
which have the characteristic of
expressing the ops in
selectively only into the soma and
therefore when these are combined
with targeted illumination they can they
they enable to reach through singles
resolution
so the an example of that is shown here
where
i'm showing uh the recording taken
from the layer to tree of the visual
cortex in vivo
where we uh first uh choose those three
targets for photo stimulation these are
the corresponding
calcium responses and then we
selectively only choose one of the three
targets and
as you can see here again from the
calcium responses this shown that we
we were able to select only the activity
of this
specific target so the the next
important step was then to be able to
perform this kind of manipulation
eventually by controlling the activity
of many many targets
and distributed in a three-dimensional
volume so this required
to modify the optical system and
what we propose is to do so by using two
independent special lay modulator
a first one creating uh
generating an illumination shape at the
grading for temporal focusing
and the second one which is used to
multiplex
these shape in 3d at multiple locations
so these optical system as is shown here
uh
then emitted multiple variants for
example this first part can be replaced
by an expanded gaussian beam and then
we call a of the technique called 3d
shot
or this can also be replaced with
alternative
shaping approach for example the
generalized phase contrast method or
a doc variance of amplitude phase
modulation techniques
so for a lack of time i won't have time
to go through all of these approaches
you can
see them described in this reference but
here let me just show you an example
where
multi-target is achieved by using a
twice an holographic system so this is
shown here
to so the first special a modulator
create
the uh analog graphic disk which is then
temporarily focused and the second one
as is shown here
multiplex this uh temporally focused
disk in 3d in this case a
50 different location uh 50 different
axle planes
and because each of this disk is
temporarily focused the access
resolution was kept below
the 12 micrometer in the entire field of
view
and which is the right size we need to
uh get
through a single server resolution
so the um we then showed that did they
shown that uh we have shown that the
waveform shaping that enable to
perform a three-dimensional uh light
generation is also compatible
with the propagation through a green
lens and so this is shown here
and where you can see that actually
it is possible to create multi
temporally focused shapes through a
green lens and so if this kind of
optical system is combined with a system
for two photon
imaging is it then possible to perform
at the same time
manipulation and calcium imaging in
depth
so the very last point i would like to
discuss now is what about the
temperature rise
in use when we increase the number of
targets then we want to illuminate
to answer to this question we developed
a few years ago a model
and to evaluate the local temperature
rise
in use under the typical condition to
perform
to photon optogenetics using a single
spot or multiple spot
and as you can see here these are the
results of the simulations
and interesting what we learn from this
is that
if the illumination time is kept before
three five milliseconds and the
average distance among the the multiple
targets
is kept larger than the corresponding
thermal diffusion length
that for this illumination time would be
of the order of 50 60 micrometer
then the total temperature rise at each
location can be
kept below the reported
damage thermal damage threshold
and this uh this model then was also
validated experimentally
in using album italian code glass
particle
and we show we demonstrate there was a
good agreement between what the model
was expecting and the
experiments and these uh now is also
done
was also recently done it directly in
vivo
so it is time to conclude and the
general conclusion i would just like to
say is that
today a combination of different
approaches which include
illumination approaches but also opsin
and reporter engineering
modeling and laser source development
put us in the on the way to manipulate
in a very precise way
neuronal circuits and therefore to uh
perform these uh what i defined the
circuits optogenetics
i would like with this also to thank now
the people of my lab of the wave from
the engineering microscopy group
the many collaborators and the financing
source especially the
nih through the brain initiative and
i would like to force to thank you for
your attention and with this also to
introduce my uh the the next speaker
dr man gui who is going to talk uh just
after me
thank you for your
the research is compact is really about
high throughput deep brain imaging
even with the events of a multiphoton
microscopy the imaging depth in
the membrane is typically about 1
millimeter so the large portion of the
mouse brain is not accessible not to
mention larger mammals
in the past miniature probe has been
utilized for example
green lines and a microprism and their
combination
a challenge of using such probe is a
very small imaging area
uh green lines is a very it has a very
simple structure
if you use a interferometry to quantify
the spatial aberration
you will find there's a strong position
dependent on its stigmatism
as a result of the two frontal figure is
very small
this is really like imaging through a
tunnel um
only you can you can only get
information from the tip only in the
middle regions all the
other area is not accessible so two
years ago i have a chance to visit a
talent aquarium they have a nice
underwater viewing gallery
walking along this gallery you can look
around at this gallery to see all the
fishes
so you have actually two degree of
freedom one is that we're calling
walking along this
gallery the other is looking around so
this inspired me to come up with a very
simple solution
i always said that the five years old
kid can come up with the solution
instead of inserting probe into brain
tissue you actually insert a capillary
the capillary is only 15 micron
thin so inside the capillary fill index
matching liquid for example water
to match the index to the brain tissue
and then you insert your immune probe
that actually can spin around
and also moving up and down in this way
all the tissues around this capillary
become accessible
to test this idea we start with two
photon microscopy
um so the idea is really uh
using similar system as conventional
method but just adding
some this is to compensate in the
spherical vibration of the green lines
and also controlling the focal depth
outside the capillary
we have a rotary stage that can spin and
translate this
imaging probe
using such control we can access all the
t-shirts around this
capillary
so in this way we can acquire acquire
maximum amount of information
just using the simple pro eventually
kind of that means we only have the
screen lines and the prism we can
achieve decent speech resolution about
1.213 transverse resolution
actually at 14.8 the field of view can
be quite
large um if you image actually 400
micron outside the capillary
you spin around you have six millimeters
for the wheel
uh from this one millimeter probe so you
can acquire lots of amount of
information
if you utilize better compound lens that
means that you have
some more components underneath the
green lines you can achieve a better
resolution for example one micron
extra resolution is about 10 microns so
this is excellent for imaging soma and
also dendrite
the key of this experiment is in the
surgery and the mechanical alignment
control side
for surgery we tested the several
methods and a very rapid one solution
that's very robust
this method is first to insert the open
end capillary into the brain tissue
as the capillary is only 15 microns thin
this is actually thinner than most the
razor edge
so you can cut this into brain tissue we
use a vacuum pump to remove tissue
inside
and then we put in a clothing capillary
at
10 micron per second controlled by a
motorized actuator and
in the end we have a cap that's designed
to match the hydra bar to prevent
dust coming into this hyderabad after
four weeks we can start a
functioning imaging that is assisted by
three cameras
one two for transverse alignment this is
a one for vertical
this is the three machine mirroring
camera we can do this alignment within
two to three minutes the key advantage
is really we have a massive amount of
tissue accessible for example we can
measure
large amount of tissue value volume all
the way from cortex to
hippocampus if you have time you can
really visit a huge amount of
neural population a key consideration
for longitudinal study is
to revisit the same neural neurons over
time in other words we need to find the
same neurons for example
we did experiment image we load the
animal
at different time points and then we
command the system to visit the same
location same orientation
we can usually find the same neuron for
example here and here there are some
tenths of a micron
offset i think eventually if we utilize
the machine variant to reset position
zero
after the insertion we can actually
reduce this error down to 10 micron
level
for calcium imaging the kernel mode we
we are doing is so-called parking image
essentially
the probe is stopped at one location we
record some calcium data and move to
another
location and of course uh there's even
faster approach possible we are also
working on the so-called spinning and
imaging that way we can acquire large
population at the same time
the signal another ratio is actually
excellent not only from the soma but
also from the dendrites
one thing we are thinking is how do we
dis broadly disseminate the semester so
many labs can start using it
one solution we come up with it's very
simple we call this thing o-ring measure
instead of changing anything to your
existing two phonon system you just have
this capillary
you have o-ring that can actually put on
to this probe by adjusting the o-rings
position we can determine how far we
want to
go inside this capillary and by
controlling the orientation we can
determine which region we want to image
therefore without changing immune system
we can achieve some of the function of a
compact system
our goal is to have a neuroscientist
start using this measure
and if you find this is really helpful
we can help you guys motorize the system
make the
system very user friendly
in the end the key message is that the
compact offer uh near three hours of
magnitude of the tissue access volume a
huge amount of tissue
can be accessible for high resolution
imaging
essentially what we did is that we're
using this capillary
to isolate the brain tissue from the
imaging probe and therefore
we convert a deep brain imaging problem
into a high resolution fluorescence
endoscope
and there has been a lot of great
invention over the past
two decades that we can take advantage
of
in summary compact is good for both
photo and two photon imaging
it's a minor change to surgical
procedure in the past we insert the
green lines now insert capillary
we can gain huge tissue access volume
there is greater flexibility
in the past if the neurons of interest
are not there you need to have a new
animal new surgery now you can
really freely explore large population
to find a neuron of interest
the other thing is that we can even
change the probe inside for example
we can switch between high resolution
probe to resolve synaptic structures
and another probe uh for really large
volume recording
so we can take one probe out and put
another one in
freely because we have the capillary
inside
it's through machine variant camera and
also the robotic
surgery we can have the system very uh
robust and reproducible
uh there are lots of things to be done
to make the speed even faster
miniaturization the other one is to make
it really small
to access small blue region the others
really make a large access to the whole
brain for monkeys
um we can have we want to have very high
resolution up to 8.7 for resolving
synaptic structures
all the way from highly fixed to free
moving animal and also from mice to
monkeys the goal is really to have whole
brain minimum brain
um neurophotonic access so that we can
perform
optical muscle skill deep brain
recording on the control
at any regions inside the membrane
i'd like to concern many of our
collaborators and also
funding from produce startup and also
equipment from hdmi and also funding
from nh and the british project
if you have questions feel free to
contact me
the next speaker is sarah abrahamson
from uc santa cruz
my name is sarah ramsen i'm an assistant
professor
at the university of california santa
cruz i've been here for a little over
two years
and i've set up an optical systems
design laboratory
today i'll talk to you about our latest
invention which is the 25
camera multi-focus microscope which is
intended for use in
neurobiology to look at the very fast
spiking dynamics by recording large 3d
volumes at over 100 frames per second
you see on this slide a prototype of our
first
m25 instrument this prototype was built
at the marine biological laboratory at
woods hall
in the lab of my collaborator jennifer
morgan who studies lamprey and what you
see
uh also on this first slide is a 25
focal plane image of the lamprey spinal
cord with presently labeled neurons
there's this conflict between 3d
resolution
and 3d acquisition speed in microscoping
that we are sidestepping using
refractive vary optic methods
in order to obtain ultra fast
images of 3d volumes
with either the optimal resolution that
the microscope is capable of
or even super resolution but i won't
talk about super resolution today
because it's not quite as fast
so that's not what we're doing with this
m25 system
thinking about imaging the basic image
that
the photographic camera or the
microscope or our
individual eye forms is a 2d image
of a 3d reality so here we see from the
f64 group
a photograph from the high sierra with
very very deep depth of focus
so we can actually see the entire 3d
scene in this image
but this is not a very useful mode in
all biology because
we cannot tell where anything is in this
image
so instead in microscopy we open up our
aperture and we get an image with
very high resolution both laterally and
axially meaning we have a
very short of the focus and we can
really see
the image plane only on cherry blossom
in central park here
this is not as powerful as in microscopy
in microscopy we have a semi-transparent
sample
and we have fluorescent label that we
look at which means that we can really
look through them
and gather the entire 3d volume this
example
is the nuclear pore complex of a mouse
fibroblast
nucleus so this focal stack is recorded
in a multifocus microscope so that is
the raw data on the camera chip
normally in resonance microscopy in
white with microscopy
you would scan through the entire volume
of the cell
and record one two three four
five six seven eight nine or however
many focal planes you needed
to cover that volume here we record all
the information at the same time to get
truly simultaneous 3d imaging and then
we can go very very fast and we have no
ambiguity
in time between the different focal
planes that we record
so the way we do this is through the
fractal optics which my favorite
microscopy
or favorite optics and we all know in
reflection in the mirror
light reflects off the mirror and in
refraction
relents the lens passes through the lens
and is refracted
in diffractive optics we can actually
multiplex the beam
and we can also change the face of that
beam so that we can
use a diffractive optic device which is
a single piece of glass
that's about this size and has a pattern
of little steps in that glass etched
into it
and by controlling that pattern very
very well when the light passes through
it
the light ripples just like a wave so
this is sort of
tapping into the wave nature of light
and by designing that
grading absolutely perfectly for our
application we can obtain
that instant focal series the way we do
that
is first imagine that we put a periodic
grating
in the fourier plane of the microscope
the fourier plane is the back focal
plane of the objective
and the microscope consists of the
objective lens and a tube lens
that together form an image on the
camera so now we pop that little grading
in
in the back focal plane of the objective
and that multiplexes the image
we also wanted to focus shift these
images so what we do then is
that we adjust the pattern on that
little optic
so that it has tinier um
tinier periods of the grading panel on
top and bigger
spacing on bottom which affects the
diffractive angle
so looking at that in the microscope we
have the objective we have the back
focal plane
we place the optic here and our
multiplex beams
if we have a periodic gradient now have
the same diffraction angle
now that we introduce a chirp to that
grating we have a larger diffractive
angle on top and a smaller on bottom and
looking at what that does to the wave
front of the light
we see that it introduces a defocus so
the plus one order
which we call the diffractive order that
goes up
uh it's it's actually focused so it will
not focus on the camera here it will
focus somewhere else
and the minus one order which is the
order that heads downward
is converging so it focuses before
the nominal focal plane and if we adjust
that pattern of this optic
perfectly we can actually make a perfect
focus image
of every plane in the sample so here is
an example of three planes
uh we normally would make this so that
we have a structure
that scatters light also left and right
so that we get that
nine nine image planes
so here is that again and
when we do this we use that at the sign
condition
to calculate how we completely remove
the out of focus phase error
of each one of those focal planes and
then we adjust
the z-step or the focus step so that it
fits our sample
sometimes we want to sample a little
finer and sometimes a little coarser in
g
here's the free open source
code in matlab that you can download if
you want to design your own refractive
optics this is a pattern that generates
nine planes
you can also generate multi-layer
patterns those
have higher photon count efficiency and
can be much more
efficient in your imaging system but
they're also much harder to make so
there's a given take there on how much
time you want to spend in the clean room
thankfully my students love spending
time in the clean room and it's really
fun and
they can make their own greetings this
is a picture from the
nanotech facility and you see santa
barbara that we use a lot
once we've made these optics we build
easy to use
user friendly imaging systems and
commission them
this is two arm two color multi-focus
microscope
for imaging transcription in yeast and
this is our
student robert zelanski who's been
working on that but what we're really
interested here is
neurobiology so this is the ke2
set of neurons in the c elegans animal
this is data from when i did my postdoc
in the laboratory of corey bargmann at
rockefeller university
and we see these sensory input neurons
which are inputs from smell
reacting to the smell of almonds so even
this powerful
this method with only nine planes was
powerful enough that we had to
completely change the way
data analysis was being done in the lab
because students could no longer
manually annotate this neural signaling
so we worked with liam polinski's group
to use intelligent algorithms
to automate this data analysis
what we really wanted though was to be
able to image all the neurons
simultaneously
so i started working on this larger
volume 25 plate microscope
and i put all of those images on the
same camera chip
by then zmos cameras was pretty new
technology
and but it was still not quite enough to
get the
high resolution in sampling that we
wanted
so today we have even better
technology at our hands we have these
small
fast sensitive cmos cameras and
i was able to redesign the multi-focus
microscope layout
to this which only uses this one
refractive
grading and then another diffractive
grading which sits in front of the lens
of each individual camera
and produces a very
corrected image of 25 focal planes at
the same time
so here's example data from that this is
gcamp muscle in the pneumatoxy elegance
and
neurons that have an injection labeled
with
calcium dye in the lamprey spinal cord
and that here is our first movie of the
sea elegance
this is nematodes from gal haspel and
it's taken in jennifer morgan's lab at
the woods hole
by my phd student at various and we just
can't wait now until this lockdown stops
so that we can start
employing this prototype and also the
product that we built in my lab at uc
santa cruz
to start looking into those fast
dynamics at
faster than 100 frames per second in
these large city volumes of
of living samples
here's my lab my students thank you very
much it was a pleasure to be here
virtually
so i'd like to talk about a technique
we've been developing called
reverberation multi-photon microscopy
to address three key challenges we'd
like to do high speed imaging
inside large volumes of thick samples
such as brain tissue
well as we all know the standard way to
image deep inside brain tissue
is to use a multi-photon microscopy
which is basically a scanning microscope
with with a pulsed laser but standard
multiphoton microscopy only
produces single plane imaging
this can be extended to two planes using
a technique of spatial temporal
multiplexing
that was first demonstrated by the jeff
squire group over a decade ago
and the idea here is to split an
illumination
beam into two paths uh one path being
longer than the other such that an
incoming pulse here
is uh split into two pulselets separated
by a few nanoseconds
and if a lens is inserted in one of the
paths then both pulselets will focus
to different depths inside the sample
and in this way a single detector
can look at both depths essentially
simultaneously
and to discriminate these depths
all you need is a fast enough detector
with nanosecond time resolution but
that's fairly standard
these days so this can be
extended to more than two depth but very
quickly it gets
very complicated
we found that a simple way to do this is
to insert what we call
a reverberation loop inside the
illumination path
such that now an incoming pulse gets
split into
basically an infinite series of outgoing
pulselets
and if in addition we add a
lens inside this loop then every time
the pulse circulates
through this loop it revisits the same
lens meaning that each one of these
pulselets
focuses to a different depth inside the
sample
but as you can see since we're using a
50 50 beam splitter here
the each pulse lit has a different
amount of energy
uh which decays uh according to this uh
power law where each pulselet
has half the power of the preceding
pulselet
and the first question one might ask is
does this pose a problem that we're
using different powers
to irradiate each
plane and to answer that question
you have to remember that we're looking
inside a scattering sample and so it
actually works up because
as we all know to go as you increase
imaging depth inside the sample you
actually need
more and more power with multiphoton
microscopy and in fact things can be
arranged
such that if you choose this interplane
separation just right
then the fluorescence coming from each
plane can be made normally
the same and the optimal uh
interplane separation to to to do this
is given by this very simple formula
where delta z the optimal separation
is the scattering length of the sample
times
the log of 2 which for brain tissue
corresponds to about
delta z of 100 microns
so here's some initial results this is
simultaneous six plane imaging
vascular imaging inside the mouse brain
in vivo
going all the way down to about 600
microns and what you just saw
was a z-stack where
all we did was scan in z from
one plane to the next and all the other
planes sort of followed so that we could
look at the entire volume here
and each frame sees
all six planes simultaneously color here
corresponds
to depth for example this is a diving
vessel right here and we have a fairly
large field of view almost a millimeter
and we're going video rate
here's uh calcium imaging uh three plane
calcium imaging
this is a g camp uh looking inside uh
the mouse olfactory bulb and this is
evoked odor response where
uh when we puff on an odor some of these
cells light up some of them actually get
dimmer
and in this manner you can look at
even the same cell the dynamics of the
same cell across
multiple layers inside the brain
so a question we often get is what about
photo damage it seems like we may be
dumping a lot of power
in our in the sample uh so to
demonstrate that it's really not that
bad
we we cranked up the power by a factor
of three compared to what we normally
use and we continuously image for
about an hour and a half and we showed
that
the the response of the cells was
basically unchanged
so photo damage doesn't seem to be a
huge issue here so
why is that well part of the reason is
that there's an inherent advantage to
distributing your planes
in the actual direction for example for
a given amount of power
if you achieve single plane imaging to
maximum depth penetration with standard
multiphoton microscopy
then with the same amount of power you
can
achieve multi-plane imaging all the way
up
to the sample surface using
reverberation multi-photon microscopy
and the only hit you took was a decrease
in the
maximum depth penetration by this
distance
delta z and if you want to achieve the
same
depth penetration as standard
multi-photon microscopy
all you have to do is double the power
and that's independent of the number of
planes that you're looking at
all the way to the sample surface
so here's some of the advantages of
reverberation multiphoton microscopy
but it does have one small disadvantage
and that's that the planes are a bit
further apart than we would like they're
about 100 microns now
so how did we address this problem well
here's a schematic of the actual
reverberation loop
and again the way it works is that a
pulse going in
gets split into a a sequence of
pulselets
coming out that are distributed in time
but they're also distributed in space
because this loop which is basically a a
4f
or relay is adjusted to be a little bit
too long
such that each pulse it coming out is
coming out at a slightly different
axial position which means that there'll
be a separation between where they focus
of delta z
and we can adjust that separation by
adjusting this loop length
such that the separation in the sample
is about 100 microns
but again 100 microns is a little bit
too long
we found a way to half that distance by
introducing a
second loop which we call the interleave
loop now here the pulse
only goes around once because we're
using a polarizing beam splitter
so what happens here is an incoming
pulse gets split
into only two pulselets that are
slightly delayed in time and space
and uh each one of these pulselets
then creates their own sequence of
reverberation pulses
that are interleaved both in space and
time and in this way we achieve
half the interplane separation
and importantly there's no power loss in
the system and everything remains
co-linear
so in summary with interleaved
reverberation multiphoton
we can achieve a 50 micron interplane
separation
but we thought even that was a little
bit too wide so what we did was we added
a piezo stepper
on our objective so that we dither the
objective up and down by only 25 microns
this halves the net imaging rate but now
we achieve a 25
micron uh interplane separation
and our future plans are to actually go
gapless by
introducing uh uh quasi-vessel beam
illumination
and as a benefit this adds robustness to
aberrations so so that's our future plan
so here are some results this is uh 10
plane imaging
in the zebrafish this was taken at 15
hertz using
a menlo system laser that we were able
to demo
this has lower repetition rate than
normal which is good for reverb
um this was even lower repetition rate
this is a coherent fidelity laser with a
lot of power albeit in the red
and here we're looking at cardiac
organoids
and finally this is just to show you
what our software looks like this is
what we see on the computer screen in
real time as we're scanning around
this is 18 plane imaging at 50 hertz
this is just
beads
so with that i would like to thank
everyone you see here in particular
devin bolyer who was basically the
workhorse behind this project
as well as all the funding sources thank
you very much
and finally i would also like to
introduce the next speaker
kaspar padgorsky from hhmi genelia farm
hello everyone i really appreciate the
invitation and i'm very happy to be here
my name is casper and i'm a fellow at
hhmi's genelia research campus
today i want to highlight a distinction
that deserves more emphasis in our
community
that's the distinction between studying
neural coding meaning the information
contained in neural firing patterns
like the receptive fields and neural
computation
meaning how that information is
transformed from inputs into outputs
as it flows through a neural circuit
this is essentially a distinction
between
what and how i don't just want to know
what a neuron responds to
i want to know how it's able to respond
that way the quote unquote logic of how
it operates
we're already very good at measuring the
what we can easily measure spikes in
response to stimuli or correlate them to
behavior
but it's harder to get at the how to
study the logic of neural computation
we need we need to know which neurons
communicate to which other neurons and
the patterns of signals they send
new methods are emerging that are going
to make it easier to study computation
such as indicators that report
sub-threshold communication between
neurons
but the tools we currently have for
measuring neural activity are still much
better at studying these things on the
left column
than in the right and to get better at
studying neural computation we're still
going to need to put a lot of work into
making tools
my lab's approach to studying
computation is not to try to record for
more neurons or record the same number
of neurons faster
expanding the bandwidth of somatic
recordings is very important
but i just don't think these types of
recordings are especially helpful for
studying computation
every neuron here receives thousands of
inputs and most of them come from other
brain areas
hidden input dominates the activity of
every neuron we record
creating latent variables that confound
our models
recording more neurons does very little
to solve that problem
so this approach regardless of scale
makes it really hard to study things
like learning rules
or other basic concepts from the theory
of neuroscience
so instead my lab is working on tools to
record comprehensively from
single neurons if we could record many
inputs from across the neurons dendrites
and its output
we could start to ask questions about
how that neuron transforms information
and unlike somatic imaging where any
given pair of neurons we record is
probably not connected
every synapse that we record onto a cell
represents one of that cell's
connections
i think that single neurons and their
interfaces are the right way to carve
nature at its joints
to study neural computation and i think
that goal deserves
as much attention as recording from more
neurons faster
so what do we need in order to make
comprehensive in-vivo recordings of
single neurons a reality
first off we need microscopes capable of
high resolution recording from large
numbers of synapses
at hundreds of hertz to see patterns of
activity on the time scale of neuronal
signal integration
our approach to that problem has been a
new type of two-photon microscope that
uses line excitation to collect multiple
1d projections of the 2d sample plane
we scan lines across the sample at 4
different angles so this is a form of
compressive tomography
and it's closely related to ct imaging
the four lines here scan the sample in
less than a millisecond
so this kind of imaging is extremely
fast by using a structural image of the
sample as a prior
we can record activity within that
structure from these high speed
compressed measurements
this approach overcomes physical limits
on how fast sequential point scanning
microscopy can go
on the left is a two photon recording of
fluorescent particles
flowing through a 100 plane volume
imaged at 1.5 billion voxels per second
on the right is glutamate imaging of
neuronal dendrites
containing hundreds of synapses recorded
at over one kilohertz
this type of imaging fundamentally
requires deconvolution
to go from the 1d measurements to the 2d
image space
so some of our work has been on the
development of efficient optimization
algorithms
that perform deconvolution subject to
the kind of spatial and temporal priors
that are available for brain activity
imaging
these are things like knowing the
structure of the sample in advance as
well as the dynamics of the indicator
and its maximum response amplitude
we've built on some of the concepts from
that first microscope to build a second
one that's more flexible
is better at 3d imaging and can also
perform richly patterned optogenetics
this microscope is designed specifically
for interrogating entire dendritic
arbors of most cortical neurons in vivo
the new microscope works by scanning a
line of excitation across a dmd
and having the dmd select which parts of
the line get relayed to the sample
the great thing about using a dmd like
this is that we can change the pattern
on it
extremely quickly and shape life
differently shape
light differently for every sweep of the
excitation line
this gives us random access to large
numbers of target sites without the
access time issues of conventional
random access scanners
when we image activity we're often
trying to measure the brightness of
regions of interest
like the dendritic spines on this image
on the left
on the right here is a random pattern of
500 such integration rowies
this is how our new microscope records
those 500 rowies
it sweeps the vertical line of
excitation across the dmd
20 000 times a second each laser pulse
illuminates a column of the dmd
if i pause this you can see that only
one rowie is open in any given column at
a time
meaning that we only measure one row we
at a time so you don't need
computational and mixing to see your
data
it also means that sparsity is not
required for this type of imaging
the microscope has two of these
scanfields that can be steered to
different locations in the sample
or overlaid to image one plane twice as
fast
it records those 500 rows from the last
slide at a mean rate
of 3.6 kilohertz each and because the
measurements are independent across rows
we can record the activity of those rows
as fast
uh we can recover the activity as fast
as we record them
another thing that comprehensive single
neuron imaging will need is better
indicators so i've been lucky to have
eric schreider and lauren luger's labs
and the genie project just upstairs for
me so we've helped them test some of
their new indicators for gaba
acetylcholine and membrane potential my
lab has also made a yellow variant of
gcamp which is efficiently excited by 10
30 nanometer fiber lasers that are
useful for these types of high-speed
imaging systems
most recently my lab has taken on
producing a new generation of glutamate
indicators
in a project spearheaded by abby agarwal
calcium indicators can report synaptic
activity but they're much more often
swamped by back propagating action
potentials
which is one big motivation to try to
use neurotransmitter indicators to
record synaptic activity
but neurotransmitter indicators have
their own limitations and there's still
a lot of work to do to understand the
signals they convey
one issue with glue sniffer is that many
variants sense glutamate spillover
these are tuning maps where brightness
encodes response amplitude and
saturation and code selectivity
glutamate signals are on the left and
spine calcium responses are on the right
this glucose variant shows relatively
non-specific signals in a lot of
membrane structures
indicating spillover
using expansion microscopy we found that
the existing membrane targeting vector
of eye glue sniffer is
excluded from postsynaptic densities and
cortex
and in general there's a variety of
properties we'd like to tune for all
neurotransmitter sensors
like membrane trafficking subcellular
localization
affinity and kinetics and of course
their brightness
sensitivity and photostability which can
vary between one photon and two photon
excitation
we've been working to improve all of
these properties of glue sniffer
so on the left here our spectra in the
presence and absence of glutamate in
vitro
for super folder glue sniffer the
previous variant and a new variant in
yellow
on the right is the two photon delta f
over f hobbies evolve the sensor using
high throughput screening under two
photon illumination
and it has especially large responses in
2p compared to 1p
this is one photon imaging in culture
the new sensors are darker in the dark
state
brighter in the bright state and more
efficient at getting to the membrane
so far we've only done a little bit of
testing in vivo and we plan to continue
optimizing variants for specific
experiment types for a few more months
in summary i think we should look to
single neurons to answer many important
questions about how the brain computes
my lab is working on methods to make
such studies possible so we're
developing microscopes we're working on
improving indicators
and other things that i've only touched
on briefly like theory and computational
tools for making inferences from these
kinds of measurements
thanks a lot for listening and i want to
thank our collaborators and the
wonderful community that makes it so fun
to work in this field
and if you want to hear more about what
we're working on please reach out to me
our next speaker will be naji from the
university of california berkeley
thank you kasper for the introduction
today i will be telling you about our
recent result
using kenohertz two-photon fluorescence
microscopy
for invisible voltage imaging
last scanning two photon fluorescence
microscopy is the most popular
in vivobrain imaging method because the
fluorescence is only generated
around the focal volume of an excitation
beam
in order to form an image typically this
beam is scanned in two dimension
in the raster pattern and the generated
fluorescent signal
detected by a non-imaging detector such
as the photomultiplier tube
to form a two-dimensional image of the
sample
this method has very high special
resolution allowing
structures as small as individual
synapses to be detected
and can also be applied at depths
hundreds of microns
into the optically opaque brand
however because of the focus is
typically scanned across the sample
using mechanical devices
its temporal resolution is not a fast
enough
in order to track the very fast membrane
potential change of neurons
in order to observe those events using
optical methods
we now require a camouflage last
scanning two photon fluorescence
microscopy method and we built such a
microscope
using a ultra fast line scanning method
called
free space angular chip enhancement dna
or facet in collaboration with kevin
chase live at university of hong kong
who initially proposed this method we
built a two-photon microscope
that is capable of 1 000 frames per
second imaging
it is based on a conventional two-photon
microscope where
it's that is equipped with a set of
global scanners
and uh that can cross scan the
excitation focus
across the sample the facet unit itself
is a passive optical device made of
three components
one cylindrical lines and a pair of high
reflectivity mirrors
that are almost parallel to each other
except for a very small angle alpha
if we look at now the red beamlets after
it was launched
into the pair of mirrors if the mirrors
are strictly parallel it will just
keep reflecting upon them until it exits
from the other side of the mirror pair
but because of the very small angle
alpha
the incidence angle keep decreasing
until it will hit one of the mirror
perpendicularly
at this point it will retro reflect and
then can be redirected
into the microscope and form a focus
the neat thing about this module is that
now if you look at
the dark gray beamlet and what you can
see is that it enters a mirror pair
at a smaller incidence angle as a result
it takes a fewer number of
reflections before it will become
perpendicular to one of the mirror
and then virtually reflected and enter
the microscope
at a different angle which means that
now this light pulse
will be focused to a different special
location
and this process in addition to being
specially separated
they are also temporarily denied so that
we can
distinguish the fluorescence that has
been generated by them so
optically what is happening is that this
pair of mirrors
basically formed a array of virtual
images of this
focal point which was then imaged into
the
the mouse brand so in this way it is
very similar to take an image
of an object in between two mirrors
however with this very simple device
what it does is that it converts a
single pulse
which will form a single focus into
array of subposes
that are temporarily separated and
especially are
separated as well and in other words
the faster units can scan the
the focus in one dimension after the
laser repetition rate which in our case
is one megahertz
in order to form a two dimensional image
we just need to scan using the
conventional variable along the
orthogonal direction
and even using a conventional galval
it's very easy
to achieve 1000 frames per second
using this microscope and the new
genetically encoded
calcium sensor device sorry genetic
encoded voltage sensor divided by the
micro name lab
at stanford we finally were able to
detect
both the sub threshold as well as the
super threshold
action potential response of neurons in
vivo as shown in this example
because we are using two photon
excitation and non-imaging detection
we will also be able to image very deep
within the the scattering brand
here we are looking at four example
neurons and four different depths from
the same brand
and that you can see from the
superstition neuron all the way down to
a neuron beyond the 500
beyond 300 micron deep we are able to
see both the action potential
as well as the sub threshold events
looking at
the response to individual action
potentials we characterize the
rise time for time as well as a delta f
over
f value for individual action potentials
and
these values are consistent with those
characterized
in vitro for the sensor
and another advantage of two-photon
excitation non-imaging detection
is that we do not worry about the
crosstalk or the signal contamination
between neighboring neurons as you can
see here
the four neurons that were active within
this uh
same field of view has a distinct
activity pattern without any sign of
crosstalk
we also explored the sensory evoked
activity from a wake mouse here we are
looking at a neuron within the primary
view context of the mouse
which is inactively active towards the
drifting grating of particular
orientations
so when we present the mouse with a
non-preferred uh
grating you can see that there's very
little
activity in terms of the membrane
voltage change
either sub-threshold or super threshold
but when the cell is presented with its
preferred
stimulus we see a very active
action potential firing as well as a
sub-threshold voltage change
and we can extract both the action
potential spiking response
as well as the sub-threshold response
and use that
to calculate the tuning curve and as you
can see the action potential based
tuning curve which is
black is a lot sharper than the
sub-threshold
response based tuning curve due to the
thresholding effect
of action potential firing this is
consistent
to the result obtained with wholesale
recording
in actual physiological method
and we also look at the onset time
of the sub as well as super threshold
voltage response after
the start of video stimulus presentation
so here we have two neurons at 345
microns
below the surface of the brain and on
top
these two traces uh it's a sub threshold
response
as you can see about in this case
uh 50 milliseconds after the onset of
the drifting gradient
stimulus we start to observe the
subthreshold response
and a very similar value was obtained
for the for its action potential firing
as well
so here is the data we obtained over 20
cells
which again consistently showing about
between 50 to 60 milliseconds of onsite
time
for the sub threshold response and this
method is a very robust
and we were able to get many million
evolved neurons from a wake mouse
and here we see a very similar action
potential
onsite time of 60 milliseconds
consistent with previous
measurement using full cell as well as
cell attached recording
so in summary using a passive optical
module based on the concept of facets
we converted a conventional two-photon
microscope into a kilohertz frame rate
rust scanning two-photon system
which allow us to marry both the sub as
well as super threshold voltage response
in vivo
so this work is led by danny woo a
poster in my lab and previously a poster
in carbon shan's lab at university of
hong kong another collaborator on this
project is michael means map at stanford
university
thank you very much for your attention
next speaker is anipasha variji
from rockstar university
i will be talking about a few techniques
that we have recently developed in the
lab that are aimed at
recording the large scale neuroactivity
in a volumetric fashion
in the scattering rodent brain as you
heard from previous talks and you're all
aware the standard tool for recording
your activity in the scattering brain
is two photon scanning microscopy
however i want to highlight some of the
limitations that are associated with
this technique
if it's applied to a volumetric
acquisition technique
imagine that we have a volume that is
about 500 cubed
in size and this would be the size of
our diffraction limited
acquisition and we want to sample this
volume at about five hertz
so simple math shows us that this
translates about 500 million voxels
which sample at five hertz means that we
have to have an acquisition rate
of about 2.5 gigahertz and since we have
to excite
each voxel at least with one laser pulse
we need to have a laser that runs at
that rate
now this has two problems first of all a
laser at that repetition rate is not
commonly available
but even if it would be it means that
the dwell time at
each of these voxels is about an order
of magnitude
shorter than the fluorescence lifetime
so we will not be able to collect any
fluorescence light out of these voxels
so we need to think about it in a
conceptually different way
and one question we ask is can we relax
the spatial resolution
without losing information now if we
look at the size of typical mass
cortical neurons
which are about 10 to 15 micron in size
we find that perhaps the the resolution
of the
diffraction limited excitation spot is
perhaps unnecessarily high
at least when it comes to imaging
neuronal cell bodies
so we can easily underfill the
microscope objective and thereby create
a larger
excitation spot but the problem with
that is that if we do that we lose all
axial localization or sectioning
capability of our tool
so we will not be able to distinguish
neurons that are on top or below each
other
so from this it becomes clear that we
need to be able to create a comparable
lateral and axial resolution and which
requires us to be able to
decouple these parameters of the beam
and
that needs us to do light sculpting
now one simple technique for doing light
sculpting that
we and others have used in the past is
the technique of temporal focusing
so the basic idea here is that we can
utilize the bandwidth that is associated
with these femtosecond pulses
to control the axial localization of
excitation
and the way that can be done is by
sending these pulses to a dispersive
element such as a grading
from where then the different spectral
component components
diverge in space and then the process
can be reversed by using a telescope
that consists of a lens and our
microscope objective
which is configured such to be bringing
all these con
spectral components together only in one
axial location
within the sample so while we can
achieve the axial localization of
excitation
by using dispersion the lateral
organization can still be achieved by
the original size of the grading and the
de-magnification ratio
of the telescope so doing that we
created a basically a
excitation spot that was isotropic about
5 micron lateral
and 5 micron axial and then we can scan
that
quickly using standard ways for raster
scanning in x y and z
now going back to the example that it
started the volume now
translates to about one million pixels
sampled at five hertz
and using one pulse per pixel which
turns out to be
the most effective way how you can
create fluorescence for
for the same amount of average power
means that we have we need to have a
laser that at least runs at five
megahertz
which is more conventionally available
also our pixel dwell time is now only
200 nanosecond
which is sufficient to collect all the
fluorescence we need
so we implemented this scanned temporal
focusing
approach and a couple of additional ways
how we could further speed up the voxel
acquisition rate
one of them was this idea of remote
focusing basically by
rapidly changing the divergence of the
beam into the back focal aperture but
by creating a conjugate plane to the to
the sample
in where we can place a light weighted
mirror on a fast scanning
voice coil we can create a scheme that
allows us to rapidly scan
along the z dimension we also
implemented
the idea of temporal multiplexing the
basic idea here is basically we can use
time
tagging of pulses as you heard in one of
the previous talks
by delaying the pulses by different
amounts and
identifying them uniquely through the
time of arrival
in the sample and then these pulses can
be done
directly to different axial locations or
lateral locations within the sample
which can be all scanned at the same
time and the fluorescence
collected on the pmt so using this
strategy
we first implemented the axial
multiplexing and looked at the mouse
ppc so here you can see now a volume
that is about 500 700
by 700 by 600 microns containing on the
order of 6 000 neurons
and we can sample here the whole volume
at about 17 hertz
uh we can also reconfigure the volume
such that these
sub volumes are next to each other
thereby we can create
a much larger lateral extent in this
case we looked at the
primary auditory cortex of the mouse so
you can see here now a volume that is
about
one millimeter by one millimeter by
point six millimeter in size
containing about twelve thousand neurons
which can be all sampled
at about five hertz while this shows the
activity if we look at
typical traces of these neurons in this
heat map representation the shear
density and number of these makes it
very difficult
to see the activities but if you zoom in
here into about 300 of these we find
that
they exhibit quite well characterized
individual time series of neurons as we
know them from
typical calcium traces in this case we
could see the responses of individual
neurons to different frequencies
uh between 6 kilohertz and 80 kilohertz
with single neurons responding to
individual frequencies
with some cross responses to neighboring
auditory frequencies
so this showed us that we can use this
approach to
do effective large scale and volumetric
recording using 2p
but eventually as we go deeper into the
sample
the signal to background ratio starts to
drop and reaches unity
around 800 to 1000 micrometer
so at that level the only thing that
helps is to switch to a higher
non-linearity
by introducing for instance three-photon
excitation
so to look at the deeper layers of the
brain
we introduced also three photons so in
this case we
implemented a second path that using a
second
laser light that was all synchronized
with our
uh original two-photon pulse strain
but had the independent path in which we
had individual
galvos dispersion compensation where we
also implemented
similar optimizations in terms of point
speed function engineering
and single pulse per pixel excitation as
i highlighted for the two photonic
case and you doing that we can now look
and go through all the layers of the
cortex all the way to the corpus
callosum
and reach into the into the ce1 neurons
of the hippocampus
here you can see a single plane
recording at about 1.16
millimeter depth with the individual
traces of the neurons here
and here a single plane recording at
1.22 millimeter
image through intact cortex at about 78
hertz
which you can see exhibits still very
nice
signal to background ratio and dynamics
of the individual neurons
one could say maybe the speed is
unnecessarily high given the response
time of g
camp so we can use the excess time to
image instead in a volumetric fashion
which is shown here from from a depth of
750 microns to about 1000 microns
here we are looking at about 400 neurons
that we are sampling now at about four
hertz
finally you can also do a hybrid
realization in which we reserved a
more intense more power intensive
three-photon excitation for the deeper
layers
and use two-photon volumetric excitation
for the upper layers so here you can see
now
simultaneously recorded activity of all
the cortical layers doing two photon
sculpted light excitation with two
photon while doing simultaneously
volumetric recording
at the deeper layers using three photon
excitation so here
we can collect from a volume that is
about um 700 by 700 by 1100 microns
containing about three and a half
thousand neurons and you can imagine
that this info
this tool can be quite useful in telling
you now information about
correlations within different cortical
layers with respect to each other
while the animal is engaged in various
behaviors but also
correlations between cortical and
subcortical layers
of the brain and i'm happy to announce
that as of this year this technology has
been licensed by
by trini uh imaging and they will be
coming out with a commercial solution
that would be available thank you
i don't know if everyone can hear me um
we're gonna get started on a q a
um yes okay so i think we're online now
for the q a session
um so thank you very much for everybody
who has uh submitted questions we have a
uh we have a long list of questions so
what we'll do is i will i will repeat
the questions that were asked by text
and then the designated um target of
that question can answer
um and i'll do this for um first few
speakers and then we'll switch to these
uh adam laboratories
so we have the question for valentina
from fajita
and the question is how deep can you
perform for the stimulation with your
method
and now valentina if you are there um
you will and you can unmute yourself
you may have stepped out for a second we
can get back to valentina um
and um the next other questions are for
man from
um we had lots of technical questions
about it um
so um i'll just go through these real
quick
one person was curious about the
resolution provided by the technique
um another wanted to know what the upper
frame rate would be
um the third person wanted to know about
the cost and whether it would work in
freely moving animals
um and another person want to know about
compatibility with other
modalities such as spinning discs or
structured elimination
um and i see that you um you were
considering answers to the questions
by text but if you can tell the entire
audience um
what you think in response to these
questions that would be great
okay so i will first maybe starting from
the resolution one
um the resolution one uh the resolution
is limiting by the imaging probe
so we tested two different immediate
probes one probe is very simple it's
just bounding a
small prism to the bottom of the green
lens
that one has about 1.2 upon 3 transverse
resolution
14.8 axial resolution and the other
probably tested is a compound lens that
is a
green lines there are some miniature
lenses and
also followed by a small prism for that
one we can reduce the x resolution to 10
micron
transverse resolution to one micron um
such resolution is okay for soma and
dendrite
but if you want to really resolve
synaptic structure you'll need a even
higher rna
we are actually working on a higher
probe that's only 0.7
but it's still under development let's
see
another question related is about a cost
so we're also thinking about how can we
really broadly disseminate this method
so one thing we propose and i'll also
show in the slider is so-called o-ring
measure
with data measure you don't really need
to change your imaging system
essentially you follow the procedure of
inserting capability
and then you just have an o-ring on your
probe then you drop this
probe inside the capillary that'll allow
you to control
how far you go into the capillary and
also you need to control the
orientation of course this is quite a
manual involved but the cost is really
low you can
less than a thousand dollars but if you
really want to motorize the system that
involve purchasing a rotor rotary stage
and also a few small cameras
i think the cost will be a few thousand
dollars and uh
right now the imaging we do are so
called a parking image
so we park the probe at one location and
take some measurement and do that
it's not really fast enough so another
module we are working on is called
spinning well you m
well you meet your data will make it
faster but it will also make the system
a little bit more expensive
but i think it's on the out of ten
thousand dollars it's a cost
um i see but you were saying that um in
terms of the
speed and compatibility it's basically
whatever you want to um put into the
system right you were saying that you
can use a
you can use a resonant galvo so it's
just a standard um
it's always limited by the how many how
much signal you can get
i think of is the miniature probe uh one
thing challenging
is uh it's not as big as the
conventional objective lens so we won't
be able to
uh collect a fluorescent signal or a
very large antenna
so your signal compared to conventional
you know imaging non-invasively
your signal will be less so this
actually set the fundamental limit
uh but if you really just want to push
for higher frame rate of course you can
switch to
resin goggle try to get it faster that's
that's the fundamental limit
uh the other thing i think with the
spinning on the imaging
you can also cover a larger volume
simultaneously
um yes um then i
yeah i mean to to follow up on that
fundamental limit you were saying is
less sensitive because you're collecting
from a smaller
area but if you had a really big
capillary that's the size of a
like that's a full width of a field of
view wouldn't that um
win exactly i think if you really for
example
uh for some of the probably listed is
the small lines
from 350 all the way to one millimeter
and two millimeter
if you can really push it to two
millimeter then i think that uh for
example for monkey brain and larger
animals then the collection will be
rather efficient really
you have a rather large antenna door
even compared to the
conventional commercial available of
black lenses
that that is really going to be
efficient but if a smaller if you really
want to minimize
miniaturize the device put it into
smaller small diameter
that's the important factor limiting how
much signal can get
great thank you so we're going to move
on to questions for sarah
so we have some questions for you sarah
from the audience um
well one is from adam himself another is
from
jerome and the third is from me so um
we're curious how your technique
compares to light field microscopy
um and then um
[Music]
i was curious about replacing these cmos
cameras
uh like these cheap cmos cameras we
bought some and we thought that they
were going to be really good based on
their specs but they didn't seem
that great yeah i saw these questions
and i actually put
text answers on them and
the first one is a light field which is
super cool right
uh however it does compromise resolution
and it's inherent i sat down with mark
lavoy and michael braxton
a lot and like tried to comp compute it
and there's no way to do it that we've
thought of that doesn't compromise
resolution
the main problem with field though has
been the computation that you need to
reconstruct the data because it's not
deterministic when this ram
sample is transparent so uh the
really it is good to get a full
resolution just regular 2d image that
you don't need to guess what it
what it is when it comes to that
light efficiency with someone else asked
we lose less than 50
with our optics which is as good as you
will ever get because we have optimized
everything completely with fabrication
and design
so you you up to a 50 loss you will take
through these
um defractive optics that we use after
that it's the same as a 2d image but you
have to remember when you take a focal
stack you take that image multiple times
and so do we
which means that you have if you compare
to 2d imaging you multiply by the number
of focal planes you have
when it comes to the cameras they are
noisier this
is the problem we they already have 70
quantum efficiency
which is not that much less than the 95
that the newest cmos
chips have which are really really great
also which we have two rods that we're
testing out this summer
side by side with the emc but
subtracting the dark image helps a lot
actually so
just cover your apertures take 16 images
take the average of those and subtract
that from every five
premier data and after that i think
computational denoising is super
exciting one of my phd students is
working exclusively almost on that and
joshua batson at the biohub has been
super helpful with this and
computational denoising
is is going to be i think super super
important
the vote on shot noise is that the
ultimate limit right but
as long as we have any electronic noise
we should first
work to remove that right and you know
during different ones of the cameras
are differently good so the imx 73 and
249 are super awesome from sony
oh great i'm writing that down okay so
um and then jerome
had a question what the delta z was i
guess
oh sarah oh jerome had a question with
the about the z
resolution oh yeah
yeah same as wide field oh how how deep
we can go the
the range so we are not sure because
what's going to limit us is when we're
going to start to see clipping inside
the objective
we've gone to 50 micron depths that's
the deepest we've done
we're going to try 100 next and since
it's all the sign of the interior of the
objective is proprietary we can't
calculate it we're going to have to try
it
until we start clipping because what
happens is that you have those planes
but they gotta enter
the objective and at some point we'll
have vignetting and we don't know when
so we're gonna try 100 microns next and
after that if that works we're going to
try 200 and we'll see what happens
but jerome was your question about the
maximum depth or the um
the resolution in the z resolution is
same as white field
no no it was the maximum depth uh
separation
the maximum separation between planes
yeah yeah so we've done two micron in
the 50 plane
and we've made optics for four micron
and we can't wait to get back in lab so
we can try them out
great um thank you sarah um
so let's um let's see if we have
questions
for um um cass
oh wait we're going to go back to
valentina i don't know valentina is back
um she may not be back so
um i will ask um casper's question
questions for casper's and casper and
we'll we'll turn it over
to adam so um so
tom kirkland from promega um hi tom has
a question about
um which um which neurotransmitters
are most important to image for for
functional imaging of the brain
and i had a question for casper about
how
how the dmds scan 500 regions of
interest at three kilohertz
um casper you are on hi um
sure i'll start with tom's tom's
question hi tom
um i i don't know that there's there's
any authority that
uh that makes the the list that you uh
that you propose um i'm i'm
definitely not the most qualified person
to be to be making the list
um you know if there's uh if there's
something that you're specifically
interested in um
i i really suggest getting in touch with
you know some of these folks that make
these things like uh
like lauren luger or lin chan or yulong
lee
um obviously uh glutamate and gaba
we have indicators for those are sort of
the most common
uh or the most prevalent excitatory
inhibitory neurotransmitters in
invertebrates uh and invertebrates
acetylcholine is very important
um but you know if you're if you're uh
working on physiology
um you know perhaps you know the most
interesting things are some of these
lesser known indicators
and so there's a lot of really exciting
work on uh
neuropeptides and neuromodulators uh
some of these uh transmitters that might
have
might have previously been considered
sort of sort of secondary you know like
like
glycine or or d serine so
i mean i think the the neuromodulators
are are really especially exciting
because they control so much
um computational state uh in
in these circuits uh so yeah every
everyone has their own sort of
wish list uh definitely uh worth uh
having that conversation with
uh with folks that are uh developing new
indicators
um uh michael your question
is is about how you sort of
how you can target many many different
independent sites
so the dmd access time is something like
50 microseconds
but that's to refresh the entire entire
image on the dmd
and the measurements are actually made
much faster they're made at the
repetition rate of the laser
so you have you know every laser pulse
is a measurement and so we make
measurements with a late with
with a line that's scanning across a dmd
so every measurement is one of these
columns
that then get sort of subselected we
throw away everything except a column of
an roi
in this sort of integration rowing mode
that i talk the most about
and so we're making measurements
actually at 41 megahertz in this case
um and and there's really very little
dead time in this case because if you
have lots of these lots of rois open in
the field of view
most of your time is spent measuring an
roi uh so if you think of sort of the
time efficiency
of this type of measurement which is you
know the important return if you want to
talk about how many different rois you
can measure
it's uh it's very very good and much
better than sort of the access times
that you could get with with aot type
scanners because the your the access
time becomes the laser repetition rate
in some cases
right i see so basically you're you're
um you're using the dmv as a mask with
little holes in it and then the
you're putting a line a laser line
across it quickly
like this right yeah and adam's lab
has done sort of a holographic analog to
this
recently with an slm where they sort of
they addressed
uh rows or columns of an slm and then
had a 1d hologram
um so uh it's these are actually uh
conceptually there's sort of
similarities in this approach where you
combine the sort of programmability
of an slm or a dmd uh with the sort of
the fast access time of scanning
a laser to sort of a spatially distinct
align to a spatially distinct point
and so that's what gives you the fast
access time that's great that's very
elegant and then there's
one more question which is from jayda
and that is do you have automated
segmentation algorithm for dendritic
rois and have you compared the
performance of gcam 7b
with igloo sniffer uh
yes okay so there's two questions um so
uh automated segmentation is extremely
important so in
in the like in slap which is that
tomographic
mode that tomographic microscope that i
that i first briefly introduced
you don't have to do segmentation in
advance you can do it after the fact
and so it can be automatic or it can be
manual uh
you can you can really do whatever you
like we uh we developed automatic
methods
uh there they're they're just based on
um elastic
is a is a random forest classifier that
you can train easily
more recently because with this new mode
where you do integration row imaging
it's really important to
rapidly segment do instant segmentation
of uh of in vivo images
there we we've used a sort of u-net
style
design followed by um some
post-processing to sort of agglomerate
and
and uh and identify synapses and that's
something that we're working on and we
really want to
uh make that as turnkey and as widely
usable
as possible um so yeah i think a very
important thing to work on
um and uh sorry
michael do you remember the second
question um it was
what if you compare gchem 7 and igloo
sniffer
and actually before you answer that we
have a question from doug kim who's one
of the conference organizers hello doug
um he wants to know if anyone should buy
10 30 nanometer lasers
uh and what color sensors and options
i'm going to make now i guess the
question is whether we should all try to
convert to 1030.
um so this is a super important
discussion topic i feel i don't know
yeah that's right so i don't think we
have time to cover all those things but
um but if you can answer on those
questions briefly that would be great
sure um so the imaging that i introduced
um
because we do this very parallel
excitation where uh at least before
these sub selections that we do
uh we have to accept we have to put a
lot of power into a lot of points at
once
i really like using fiber lasers to do
this and we actually saw fiber lasers in
a couple other places ali pasha
um showed a a 1030 a 1030 laser
as did jerome um or 1040.
um and so these lasers are great because
they're very stable and they generate a
lot of pulse power that's hard to do at
sort of the classic gcamp gfp excitation
wavelengths
and so uh we recently uh made a variant
of of gcamp that
is yellow it's it's we've changed it to
a yfp chromophore which took a little
bit of work and that
allows us to excite it very well with
those fiber lasers
it's a wavelength that is really great
for exciting rfps as well
so there's great arguments for
using maybe a combination of yellow and
red fluorescent proteins with these sort
of inexpensive and powerful fiber lasers
there's also you know great
semiconductor lasers at those
wavelengths as well
so we we don't get great snr out of
gcamp because gcamp excites about 14
times more poorly
at 10 30 than it does at its peak we
have done imaging with g-cam
you know gcamp is a great sensor so you
can sort of overcome that you can take
that hit
but uh it was really great for us to
move to yellow
indicators and uh glue sniffers is very
bright especially under two photon
uh gives gives great signals and uh
we're only working on improving some of
the
sort of challenges for using it for
synaptic uh signaling
okay i'm gonna turn it over to adam
thanks
great um so there are a couple of
questions for
naji um one of them
from uh my former grad student lynlin
fan
is um how long can you use the faceted
uh approach with the asap voltage
indicator i guess that's a question
related to photobleaching rates
and then the second question is could
you resolve any
uh functional dynamics down to
sub-cellular structures
using the facet technique with asap
and those are two great questions so for
the isab
sensor that's in our paper which is
isop3b
we were able to imagine a cell for a
cumulative 80
seconds and it wasn't completely
bleached we stopped the experiment
because we didn't need to image it
anymore
but this 80 seconds are not continuous
so we have we image for one second
and then we wait for 2.5 seconds what we
found is that
the brightness of the fluorescent
actually go back
almost completely now before the
shutdown we were actually testing new
sensors
from the main lab which in the
preliminary testing we actually didn't
see
any photographing within the limited
amount of exposure
it's possible that the base of
fluorescence is quite a bit dimmer in
that sensor
so i'm very hopeful that this wouldn't
be an imitation
and it's already another limitation even
with 3d for many
experiments that people may be
interested in um so
on the second question is about uh um
sorry my cat was trying to attack me so
please remind me what's the second
question
it was about uh resolving sub-cellular
voltage dynamics yes
right that's really the you know the
ultimate goal is if we can see
all the membrane depolarization on
individual synapses that would be great
with the current sensor it's uh it's not
we don't have that sensitivity
to see it yet but that's ultimately the
goal
great thank you um another
um question for you now is are the
individual pulse slits that come from
the uh faucet technique
equivalent in power and other optical
properties or is there some drift as you
go across the
um the array right so the process
differs by how many times
they got reflected on those mirrors and
the mirror has very high reflectivity
it's higher than 99.9 percent so even
from the first to the last process
their energy difference would be less
than eight percent even if the
reflectivity is only 99.9 and the mirror
also has very
low uh group velocity dispersion which
means that
those processes also wouldn't differ in
terms of how long they are
the the main thing that uh distinguish
the process especially from the very
first one to the very last one
is a is a beam size because uh might
deflects
the more you propagate it the size will
get bigger so in our in the figure one
of our paper we actually characterize
the points by function of individual
process
so basically the the most denied posts
has a higher
effective numeric aperture because it
fills the back aperture of objective
mode
but that's really the main difference
among the pulses
great thank you um maybe we'll
end with a question which is to all of
the speakers so
um we'll let you speak in whatever order
you like
is about data management and uh
you know but the blessing and the curse
of high throughput microscopy
is that you have large quantities of
data coming in at high speed
is there any hope for common
analysis or handling software or does
everybody have to
um write uh their own
software and um what are people doing
about that challenge so now since you
answered the last question maybe you
want to
talk about it yeah um so
so with facet we do have very high data
rate
and uh it would be great if we can all
have the same kind of data connection
pipeline um but uh but practically just
like in all the different methods
described here
we are taking data in very different
ways like either raw data coming in for
jerome's case it's gonna be you know at
different depths and in my case will be
a different
natural position so in the initial stage
of data analysis i do not see how a
universal
pipeline would apply to everybody but
now of course once we
use fpga or other method we can get the
reduced data size then many of those
data basically going to be
exactly the same um just uh you know
metrics
representing 2d two-dimensional
three-dimensional information
and with that we basically use whatever
that is already existing
on data analysis pipeline many of them
are open sources and
and we found them to be very useful for
us
so ali pasha i'm curious what um your
lab is doing with
uh since you spoke specifically about
these huge data rates that
these experiments can generate sure yeah
i mean um i think as a general comment i
think what would be
probably useful in my view would be to
develop something that would be more
like a
common platform not necessarily a common
uh
data processing pipeline it has to have
features to be
adaptable to the different uh
differences in these imaging modalities
so we specifically are
uh have been very um successfully using
the
kaiman that was developed by uh liam
peninsky's lab
because it has certain uh products that
we could modify and
and match and optimize for for our
particular imaging modality
and otherwise i think uh you know having
the infras
infrastructure in place uh for for for
shipping data
you know over over networks at high
speed because just uh
copy paste becomes uh not just such a
simple task so having all of this
uh infrastructure is also another
important thing that we
we implemented a long time ago uh both
in terms of processing
also transfer rates great
thank you um so
maybe i'll end coming back to valentina
because i think she's back
now on the audio uh the question for you
valentino was
how deep can you perform the photo
stimulation
ah um her audio still seems to be
not working
okay um in that case
i think um we should uh thank all of the
speakers
for uh their uh presentations
and uh for uh answering the questions
and uh to thank all of you in the uh
internet uh in the ether for uh coming
to this uh session
and um wish you all the best with your
research
thank you yes thank you everyone thanks
to all the speakers in the audience